my name indi means patience in igbo
but i'm probably one of the most
impatient people you've ever met
i was in such a rush to enter the world
that i was born in the parking lot of
the university of nigeria teaching
hospital true story
agriculture was my favorite subjects in
school
my mom remembers me squealing for joy
when i ran home from school and saw
green beans
ready for harvesting or when i sold a
bag of avocados in our local market
i considered studying agriculture in
school
but instead opted study business and
started in corporate america
but many twists and turns
led me back to my first love
consulting working with entrepreneurs
and then starting businesses
a defining moment for me was in 2007
during the first world food crisis in my
adult life
i recognized how connected we were
all price shocks
led to cereal price hikes which affected
bread prices
all over the world
and the most vulnerable were hurt
fourteen years later my impatience has
grown
we're even more connected
and our food ecosystem is even more
broken
thankfully the rockefeller foundation
has some pioneering research on the true
cost of food in the united states
which indicates that even though we
spend 1.1 trillion on our animal food
expenditure we actually spent 2.1
trillion
on costs linked to health
and climate
all because of our broken food ecosystem
these same statistics
have been replicated all over the world
in fact according to the un food system
scientific group
our food system is value destroying
there's a need for urgent action
from at least three lenses
a health lens
an equity lens
and a climate lens
starting with the climate lens
we must modify how we grow food and
reduce food waste
our food ecosystem is one of the largest
contributors to climate change
we keep cutting down trees
to grow more food
and we keep wasting food which ends up
in landfills and rots generates methane
the good news is that we have the
technology and the science today
to grow enough food to feed the world
and to address our food waste problems
we have the knowledge but we're not
using it
they're exciting examples from my
ecosystem where we're seeing
dramatic impacts
the sungai center in benin republic
educates young africans on regenerative
agriculture and zero waste total
production
and one of these young people
is doing just that
through his company bioloop
he's feeding waste
yam peels
to black soldier fly lava
they're growing really quickly
and becoming wonderful fish feed
the by-products
and the residue from this process is
wonderful soil supplements
and the entire production process is run
on renewable energy
through my work with sahel consulting
we're demonstrating that farmers can
double and triple yields
without hurting the environment
we're using technology and science from
our local research institutions and
we're proving that in africa they're
great examples for the rest of the world
to emulate
now we need to scale these interventions
and we need to ensure that our
governments our private sector our
farmers are incentivized to change
behavior and to improve lives
if you're as impatient as i am you also
have a role to play
by reducing the food waste in your home
every single person here can take up a
policy to ensure that their schools
their companies
their civil society groups have a
sustainability policy and a food waste
policy and please don't tell your
children to finish their dinner because
they're hungry children anywhere tell
them to finish their dinner
because it's good for the environment
and healthy food is good for them
second we must ensure that healthy food
is affordable and accessible for the
most vulnerable
this is a huge challenge
on healthy food
kills and we know this
one out of every five deaths is linked
to unhealthy food and yet one third of
our world's population cannot afford a
healthy diet
this is a big challenge
now food is medicine
healthy food gives us long and
productive lives and during kovit we've
seen the impacts
of closures
shipping challenges
that have affected food prices and the
most vulnerable have had to shift from
healthy diets to unhealthy diets because
they're cheaper
this has caused more damage
to lives all over the world we must take
a stand on this and we can learn a lot
from africa
the hatzi bay people in tanzania live in
harmony with the land
and through their lives we've seen
the ability to have a healthy diet they
eat 10 times more fiber than the average
american
oftentimes we don't realize that even in
our own traditional communities we have
so much to learn
in urban communities we also have
exciting social enterprises like mdoc
that's using digital technology cell
phones and training to get urban
populations that are struggling with
diabetes high blood pressure and so many
other health challenges
linked to eating ultra processed food to
shift to more traditional diets and
they're seeing measurable outcomes
we must scale these type of
interventions but we must also hold our
private sector companies responsible for
the amounts of sugar and salt contained
in food we must set standards for what
healthy food is and define healthy food
according to plant-based diets low salt
low sugar and keep all of us accountable
we must also encourage our governments
and ensure that at the local state and
federal level our school feeding
programs prioritize healthy food our
public procurement programs prioritize
healthy food and collectively
we ensure that we keep
the standards high for everybody every
child
if you're as impatient as me you must
also set standards and hold those in
your space of influence accountable for
delivering on healthy food for the most
vulnerable
third we must support small and
medium-sized enterprises
in the food ecosystem small and
medium-sized enterprises are the bedrock
of our economy they create jobs they're
innovative
and they can pivot very quickly
but during the pandemic we've seen
something
they're most affected by shocks the
mortality rates of small and medium
sizes and
size enterprises in the food ecosystem
has been quite high
now through my work i've seen the value
and the power of small and medium-sized
enterprises i'm the co-founder of a food
company called ace foods
we have over 50 of our staff are women
50 of our border women and we produce
healthy foods sourced from over 10 000
farmers
through this company
we're demonstrating that when you
empower women
you empower communities one product that
we sell has a ripple effect through the
entire ecosystem
another company that's worthy of
emulation is twiga using mobile money
and cell phones to connect farmers to
urban retailers
now their efficiency and removing the
middlemen
creating shorter value chains ensures
that not only the farmer benefits the
retailer benefits but the consumer has
access to healthier food
and finally i'm most inspired by these
dynamic women entrepreneurs
through nourishing africa i work with
entrepreneurs in 37 african countries
who are scaling sustainable businesses
building healthy food companies and
demonstrating that strong small and
medium-sized enterprises committed to
sustainable agriculture and healthy food
can become change agents we need to
support our small and medium-sized
enterprises creating an enabling
environment for them providing catalytic
financing enabling them to scale and
supporting women owned businesses
especially businesses run by young
women in the food ecosystem we're often
told
to be patient when we plant the seed to
let it grow
we're often told to let the
vegetables simmer so that the juices
will flow we're told that india maca
patience is a virtue
but a wise woman was said
for
the dreamer impatience is a virtue
i am
impatient about the current pace of
change in the food ecosystem
and i think we all must be courageous
and bold to transform this landscape
the next time you eat a meal ask
yourself a few questions
who grew this food
where was it grown
when was it grown how many steps and
stops did it make before it got to your
table how much food waste was generated
because of this meal
let your answers influence your next
meal
the fact that you have a choice
gives you privilege
and also gives you a voice
to demand that the solutions to the food
ecosystem align with what works for
people and planets
we must collectively
create a food ecosystem that works not
just for us
but for future generations
our children and grandchildren will hold
us accountable for what we chose to do
today
to transform the food ecosystem thank
you so much
you